and they'll face zach davies who has not
allowed a run in 11 and two thirds in
two starts against st louis this year so
a high leverage count for goldschmidt
early
davies ends up missing that's been his
biggest problem this year a career-high
walk raid and goldschmidt is a board for
arenado with one away
arenado cranks one on the first pitch
but it's playable to left for wisdom
davies has been behind in a couple of
counts in this first inning
and tried that corner again
not given to o'neill and it's two walks
in this first inning for zach davies
that'll bring up matt carpenter numbers
just have not been there hitting a
paltry 193.
first pitch swinging and he beats the
ship with a base hit goldschmidt around
third he will score and matt carpenter
back in these old stomping grounds gives
st louis a one to nothing lead in the
first
well you mentioned not wasting any time
arenadoes offered at the first pitch
carpenter comes right up and goes after
the first pitch
said he beat the shift this is just a
line shot in the right
[Applause]
good way for the cardinals to get going
they'll deal with this left-hander who's
coming off an outstanding game where the
cardinals topped it out against kevin
gausman and the giants that's kwang hyun
kim
on the outside corner that's something
that kim loves he loves the back door
stuff against right-handed pitch
right-handed hitters and he gets a
smooth k to start off base it for rizzo
here is bios
baltimore chop to second waiting there
perfectly was carpenter and that is a
beautifully executed double play by the
veteran infielder debuted last year
after signing with the cardinals in
2019.
boy horner goes after one way inside but
it gets away from molina so it'll be a
strikeout
and either a wild pitch or a pass ball
horner will take it and a base runner
aboard here in the second for the cubs
the infield a double play depth the
pitch a swing and a double play ball to
short out at second carpenter to first
double play six four three
two double plays in two innings in back
of huang yun kim
here's the bridge from davies to aaron
at the street too he's not going the
pitch ground ball to short diving stop
by
buyers put a second wall over to first
not in time
buy as a sensational play at short back
hand of the ball did a reverse pivot
from his knees got the ball to horner
for the fourth out and they almost
doubled up aronado at first what a play
by bios
and he walked the guy that's uh well
he's a pretty good player and bryant but
now he's got to face another pretty good
hitter and anthony rizzo who's singled
in the first inning
next pitch is hit in the air to right
field he's going to stay in the park
over to his right is the right fielder
carlson and he dives to make a play
what a play it was but poorly judged and
the wind took it and carlson almost
dropped it just a normal fly ball that
he had to come in and catch on the very
end of his glove my goodness cardinals
have a one-nothing lead as we to the
fourth inning and yadier molino will
lead things off oh two
little soft roller to horner
will retire molina to start the enemy
and now back to the top turning it over
to carlson in an rbi spot two on two out
of the fourth and the three two swinging
a high pop fly this should end the
inning
baez near second is calling he's
pointing to the ball and makes the catch
his order here in the fourth against kim
baez with a ground ball double play to
end the first inning
one and two bios rolls one out towards
short gonna be a tough play for de young
his throw not in time
infield single bias
i thought arenado would try to get there
he tried and just couldn't and so it was
up to the shortstop to make the
backhanded play and baez has good speed
gets the infield single
so the wild pitch sends baez to second
and the next pitch is swung on and
missed by wisdom the yachty's gonna have
to throw to first base and he does
indeed get wisdom as that ball was in
the dirt so a strikeout 2-3
off the fists popped up
carpenter's there for out number two
three and two audi at half time run at
second in the fourth
got him swinging look at kim pumped up
paul goldsmith they're playing in the
fifth inning and goldie has been on with
a walk and a base hit he has scored the
only run in the game whack paul
goldschmidt annihilates that ball my
goodness onto wavelength
13th of the year
extends the hit streak and that was a
blast
my goodness the seventh of his career at
wrigley
and he tattooed it two-nothing first
non-single for a hit in this game
between the two teams davies responsible
for o'neal on base and he gives way
to adam morgan and edmond rips it deep
to left field
another life
and another cardinal home run here in
the fifth a home run to the bleachers
for tommy edmond and a three-run inning
in the fifth nothing cardinals
the fifth home run of the year for tommy
and that's his second career home run
against the cubs both at wrigley field
and a very good move by mike shield he
pinch hits
tommy edmond for matt carpenter even
though matt carpenter had an rbi in this
game chase morgan here's dan winkler
winkler the right-handed pitcher paul de
young from the stretch the pitch
a swing and a high fly ball center field
moving back on it he's at the wall and
this one is gone it's in the basket a
home run for paul deyoung
a two-run shot and a three-home run
fifth inning for the cardinals
i smell the coffee brewing the cardinals
have scored six huang young kim is
finding a groove these last two two and
a half starts ryan sends one deep to
center field but playable for bader
one away brings up javier bios he hits a
base hit up the middle avi collecting
his second hit of the game
on after that base hit by baez gubs
needed somebody to launch one and get
cubs back into this game they've been
shut out so far here
with two outs in the six maybe wisdom
can get a breaking ball or something out
over the plate
well check swing back to kim wait look
how athletic he is
wisdom is out so no runs one hit one
error kim went six sparkling innings and
scattered five weekly hit singles this
one a double for horner against cabrera
so now ian happ to the plate
off the fists of hat
goldschmidt and edmund are out
goldschmidt navigating and he makes the
grab
back to second base goes horner one away
2-1 to sergio
golf sitting to right for carlson
corner will tag from second but he's not
going to go too far carlson has one of
the best arms
in baseball from the outfield
gas
98 strikeout
last chance for the cubs with two away
here's half two outs in the ninth in a
2-2 delivery gantt to half and that'll
do it
rubber game of this series tomorrow